this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building a website more details on them
later let there be floods of floods in
the bourgeoisie more blood as much as
possible with these words a newspaper
published by the Soviet Red Army
welcomed the reins of blood sweeping
through Russia in late 1918. it was a
period which became known as the Red
Terror the systematic elimination of
anyone who could pose a threat to the
recently established Soviet government
the engine behind the Red Terror was the
feared Checker the first secret police
force established by Vladimir Lenin's
Bolshevik Revolution an organization
which would later evolve into the feared
KGB and at the head and heart of the
Checker there stood one man staunchly
loyal to Communism and single-minded in
his Relentless oppression of the enemies
of the state this is the story of iron
Felix jazinski
foreign
was born on August 30th 1877 according
to the Julian calendar or September the
11th according to the Gregorian calendar
his birthplace was the town of jejunovo
modern-day Belarus back then part of the
Russian Empire Felix was the sixth of
eight children born to Edmund a Jewish
gymnasium teacher and Helena the
daughter of Professor yanashevsky a
Polish nobleman Edmund had been hired by
anashevsky to tutor his daughters while
Edmonds did tutor them he also did so in
the most inappropriate manner the 25
year old Edmund seduced the 14 year old
Helena and other two were forced to
marry while being pregnant with her
sixth child Eleanor had a bad fall and
was at risk of miscarrying her baby was
born prematurely but miraculously
healthy hence his parents decided to
name him Felix meaning happy or Lucky in
Latin but this lucky child would soon
become fatherless as Edmund died of
tuberculosis in 1882. Helena took great
care of Felix and his siblings education
raising them as Catholics little Felix
was so taken up by religious teachings
that he expressed a desire to become a
priest at the age of 13 Felix was sent
to study in a boarding school in
villeneux modern-day Lithuania also part
of the Russian Empire as he Grew Older
he lost interest in academics and
religion and developed an antagonistic
streak towards the stifling autocratic
rule of the Tsar he was more interested
in learning about the conditions of the
working class eventually developing a
fascination with Marxist ideology at the
age of 17 Felix joined an underground
Marxist Group which put him under
scrutiny from education authorities when
he publicly insulted and slapped a
German teacher that was the last straw
and he was expelled from his gymnasium
after the expulsion Felix became an
active propagandist on behalf of a
Social Democratic revolutionary group
which advocated the overthrow of the
Tsar as well as polish and Lithuanian
Independence the young for our brand
spread the word of Communism among
Factory workers and students and
activity which earned him his first
arrest in 1897. Felix was first
imprisoned at the Cow nurse prison in
Lithuania and in August 1898 it was sent
in internal Exile in the lint 900
kilometers Northeast of Moscow there he
found moment in a tobacco Factory and
despite constant police supervision
Felix managed to stay in contact with
his comrades back in Poland and
Lithuania he also organized frequent
political meetings with fellow workers
which eventually prompted his second
forced relocation to kygo De scoia 430
kilometers north of malinsk it was
December and temperatures plummeted to
40 degrees celsius below zero
josindinsky endured in human conditions
and a medical examination in February
found him to be on the verge of death
but the Resolute revolutionary pulled
through and as spring came he started
his plan to escape Felix took up hunting
embarking on long trips in the woods his
police escort had a hard time tailing
him but the budding Hunter always
returned home by August 1899 the police
escort had got used to this routine and
that's when Felix left for good
zejanitsky sailed a boat along the karma
River then boarded a train and reached
vilnus in September before the police
even had time to issue a warrant for his
arrest during late 1899 and early 1900s
Felix worked hard unite the Social
Democrat movements of Lithuania and
Poland in January he traveled to Warsaw
to set up a clandestine printing press
but on the 23rd he was arrested a second
time after incarceration in Warsaw in
January 1902 jezanitsky was transferred
to Moscow and from there he was to be
deported to the motherland of Exile and
suffering Eastern Siberia
[Music]
in February 1902 Felix was taken to ikut
north of the border with Mongolia there
he and other political prisoners were
placed in a temporary facility awaiting
transfer to another destination but
weeks and months dragged on and the
Exile sent a letter to the prison
superintendent demanding to know what
fate awaited them no reply came in May
the facility became overcrowded with an
influx of violent common criminals Felix
interpreted this as a move by the
authorities to intimidate the political
prisoners and decided to launch a
preemptive strike as per established
prison law he picked the biggest meanest
looking convict walked up to him and
knocked him out cold then his fellow
comrades surrounded the common criminals
and threatened to launch an all-out
battle the prison superintendent arrived
just in time to prevent a riot but it
was only a temporary respite on the
morning of May 6th Felix LED his
comrades into a mutiny they overpowered
the guards and raised a red flag over
the Prison Walls declaring it could to
Free Republic the police and the Army
surrounded the prison but authorities in
Saint Petersburg advised the local
Governor to settlement peacefully after
protracted talks with shizanitsky the
governor agreed to the prisoner's
demands which were essentially to be
taken out of the prison and into their
place of Exile the governor yielded and
on the 12th of May a transport was
arranged towards yakut some 3 000
kilometers to the Northeast at a halfway
stoppedinitsky feigned illness and on
June the 12th he gave the police the
slip once more by the 29th he was back
in Warsaw Felix may have pulled a sickie
on his latest evasion but he had
actually contracted tuberculosis
sometime in the early 1900s despite this
illness he worked tirelessly In 1902 and
1903. he founded newspapers traveled to
Krakow Berlin and Switzerland all the
while climbing the ranks of the Social
Democrat movement and advocating unity
amongst all revolutionary movements
within the Russian Empire during this
intense period of activity he also
became an admirer of the works and
ideals of another rising star in the
Marxist constellation one Vladimir Lenin
in January 1904 the russia-japanese war
broke out Lenin's view was that asari's
defeat would hasten the fall of
autocracy
agreed and intensified his efforts in
spreading anti-saurus propaganda as well
as organizing anti-war strikes and
demonstrations on January the 9th 1905
Russian troops shot and killed peaceful
demonstrators in Saint Petersburg which
ignited the first Russian Revolution
news spread quickly to Warsaw and Felix
was at the center of revolutionary
activity by disseminating leaflets
organizing party cadres and training
detachments of armed workers this effort
culminated on May the 1st with a massive
demonstration which degenerated into
another bloodbath dejanitsky was not
deterred and organized an inter-regional
Social Democrat Party Conference on July
the 17th to plan further action but the
police got wind of it and raided the
meeting premises arrested in Felix for
the third time look are you a Creator
looking to present your work online
would you like an online presence that
looks neat and professional yet still
unique for your brand then today's
sponsor Squarespace is the perfect
solution for you as they provide an
all-in-one platform for building the
website of your dreams choose from
stunning templates that can be tailored
within minutes to reflect your
creativity and personal brand or Style
with more than 40 design options every
website will look perfect on any device
due to squarespace's mobile ready and
responsive designs creating a website
from scratch has never been easier or
quicker with squarespace's easy drag and
drop feature you can do text photos
Galleries and much more without any
complicated coding or to maximize your
content in a way that reflects your
brand identity while Squarespace members
feature makes this simple and easy
allowing you to unlock a new Revenue
stream by offering exclusive access to
gated content for your most loyal
customers every website also comes
equipped with built-in SEO tools like
meta descriptions and keywords which
guarantee that search engines can find
and properly index your content quickly
also there's automatic backups ensuring
all your publishing activities are
secure and up to date at all times while
their top quality hosting platform
provides fast loading speeds on all
devices regardless of geographic
location or connection type they also
offer 24 7 customer support along with
their extensive library of how-to videos
ranging from customizing elements to
developing more complicated integration
strategies so check out squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch your new website go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and start building your online
presence today and now back to today's
video this time Freedom came courtesy of
Tsar Nicholas II who granted limited
reforms in October and an amnesty in
November nonetheless JoJo nitsky did not
trust the SARS concessions and urged his
comrades to take up arms and acts with
arms in our hands
in early 1906 josinski focused on
propaganda work spreading revolutionary
ideals amongst Farm laborers and
infantry soldiers two sectors thus far
ignored by socialist agitators this
incessant work brought in respect and
notoriety among the cadres of the
Russian Social Democratic labor party
the rsdlp who invited him to their
Congress in Stockholm in April 1906. it
was at this conference that jezanitsky
first met in person with Lenin from then
on they would be lifelong friends and
collaborators Felix Orrin Lenin a
teacher and a natural leader Lennon saw
and Felix are Relentless supporter a
brave Man of Action who could enact his
vision by driving revolution in the
Polish territories jejunitsky did not
disappoint in December 1906 he was at
the Forefront of a protest against a
factory lockout in Lords Central Poland
a protest followed by a sport arrest
while in jail Felix was elected as a
member of the rsdlp Central Committee he
was now a big shot in the party and was
able to celebrate upon his release on
bail in May 1907 but as his visibility
increase so did his chances to be
arrested by the akrana the feared
Sarah's secret police in fact jezanitsky
who was seized once more on April 3 1908
and later sentenced to be exiled for
life in Siberia by now Felix was a pro
at escaping the clutches of the Russian
police on November 23 1909 he quietly
left the remote Village of tayusevo and
apparently his guards noticed only three
months later by then jejunitsky was
enjoying the warm sun and fresh Breeze
of Capri southern Italy alongside fellow
revolutionary Maxim Corky after the
brief break jajanitsky returned to
Poland where he resumed his underground
activity trying to escape the grasp of
the akrana the Revolutionary also found
time for more pleasant Pursuits as he
met and fell in love with fellow party
member Sophia Muscat the two married in
August 1910 and was soon expecting their
first Charles in December 1910 however
Sophia was arrested and sentenced to
Exile before departing for Siberia she
gave birth to their son yarn in June
1911 Felix was always on the move so
yarn was entrusted to Sophia's father
jejunitsky nonetheless tried to visit
his son as often as possible it was
during one of these visits that he
narrowly evaded yet another okrana raid
but it was only a matter of time before
the secret police finally caught him and
Felix was arrested yet again at the end
of 1912. for the next four years
janitsky was kept under a strict prison
regime first in Warsaw then in oil and
finally in Moscow there was no hope of
escaping now as the Revolutionary was
kept in Chains most of the time and
suffered frequent beatings meanwhile in
the outside world the Great War had
broken out the competent contact in the
war by Sir Nicholas II and exacerbated
the discontent of his subjects until
tensions erupted in the February
revolution of 1917. joshanitsky and
other socialist and communist agitators
were released from prison but this was
not yet the main Revolution that they
were planning for sure the Tsar had been
ousted and replaced by the provisional
government of Social Democratic lawyer
Alexander karensky but karensky was a
moderate unwilling to enact the radical
forms advocated by Lenin and eager to
keep Russia in the war the bigger people
finally took place with the October
Revolution When Vladimir Lenin and his
Bolshevik supporters overthrew
karensky's government and firmly took
power
[Music]
well maybe not so firmly Lenin's
revolutionary government was at risk of
collapsing in its very first few weeks
of existence the German and Australian
Empires held parts of Ukraine and the
Baltic states a counter-revolutionary
force known as the white Army formed in
southern Russia and Siberia prompting
the start of the Russian Civil War
reactionary saboteurs roamed the streets
of Moscow and petrograd socialist
factions not aligned to the Bolsheviks
threatened to rest power from Lenin and
his comrades and top it all off peasant
revolts erupted within
bolshevik-controlled territory this
atmosphere of actual or perceived
threats prompted Lenin and his
government to create a special unit to
root out the enemies of the Revolution
this was called the all-russian
extraordinary commission for combating
counter-revolution and sabotage or more
simply the extraordinary commission
known by its Russian acronym of Checker
the first Soviet Secret Police in secret
service was born on December 20 1917 and
its primary goal was to put on trial in
the Revolutionary tribunal those who had
committed sabotage acts and the
counter-revolutionaries
to develop methods for fighting them
Lennon himself appointed the chairman of
this new unit he was after a man of
action one fanatically devoted to the
ideals of the Revolution and no spoilers
here but the choice fell on
comradezinsky after being the target of
a pervasive secret police unit the
okrana for much of his adult life
janitsky would soon unleash his own
operatives against his enemies but the
head of the Checker had a daunting task
ahead considering that he was initially
assigned only 12 operatives under his
command all the checklists could do in
their first days in operation was to
prevent liquor stores in Moscow from
being looted however janitsky soon
expanded the ranks of Pacheco recruiting
new members from the best and brightest
amongst the red guards he then
concentrated the efforts of the Checker
and crushing the socialist revolutionary
movement this was considered to be the
main opposition to the Bolshevik
government already in these early days
of actionitsky clearly laid out what
were his favorite methods and what his
police force stood for quote always
stand for organized Terror this should
be frankly admitted terror is an
absolute necessity during times of
Revolution our aim is to fight against
the enemies of the Soviet government and
of the New Order of
the Socialist revolutionaries responded
a bystaging a street demonstration in
petrograd in July 1918. jezanitsky was
not amused and he Unleashed his
checklists against the protesters
firefights erupted and 350 demonstrators
were killed in the riots on August 17th
the Socialist revolutionaries retaliated
by assassinating Moses heritsky head of
petrograd's check section janitsky could
not forgive the killing of one of his
most trusted men he left Moscow in haste
and descended upon petrograd eventually
tracking down and arresting the Assassin
Leonard kanagisa initially a Lenin was
against extracting violent retribution
on kanagai sir but he soon changed his
mind on August 30th someone fired three
shots against Lenin's car in Moscow
wounding him in the neck and shoulder
the shooter was identified as Fanny
Kaplan a former supporter of the
Revolution now disillusioned with the
Bolsheviks kanagisa and Kaplan were
executed and many many more deaths would
follow Lennon his government and his
security apparatus could not tolerate
such blatant attacks on their Authority
on September 2nd and the Checker issued
the Red Terror order the set of
directives to arrest a wide rare enemies
of the state targets included members of
socialist non-bolshevik parties
industrialists entrepreneurs Merchants
landowners members of the clergy and
Military Officers as well as their next
of Kim Checkers were ordered to imprison
these hostile elements in forced labor
camps the early incarnation of the
infamous Gulag system but shizanitsky
also authorized his men to summarily
execute anyone who resisted arrest by
early October 1918 jajanitsky's
checklists had arrested more than seven
thousand alleged enemies of the state of
which 800 were summarily executed and
this was impetigan alone from his
hospital bed Lennon urged nitsky to ramp
up the brutality of the killings and to
favor public hangings to send a message
to the trembling citizens besides
hangings the checkers to distinguish
themselves by the variety of methods
applied to the killings most victims
were first stripped of all valuables
including gold teeth which were
distributed among the secret police
agents then they were liquidated with a
bullet to the head and acceler charge if
the targets were believed to be
sympathizers of the white army they were
burned alive drowned in rivers or hacked
to death to perpetrate the most brutal
killings or acts of torture josinski
encouraged the recruitment of sexual
deviants and Psychopaths many of whom
were raised to senior positions within
the Checker the Red Terror order was
officially enforced until the end of
October 1918 although jezanitsky's
acolytes continued to perpetrate mass
killings until the end of the Russian
Civil War in June 1923. during September
and October the death toll throughout
Bolshevik controlled Russia had risen to
15 000 confirmed casualties but the
unofficial nature of the massacres makes
it impossible to estimate a precise
number likely up to 200 000 citizens
died at the hands of the check during
its first years in operation whilst
czechists were busy rounding up and
executing enemies of the state Felix
josinski worked tirelessly from his
headquarters in La Bianca Square Moscow
the head of the Checker barely survived
on a diet of mint tea and bread
compiling endless lists of targets for
imprisonment or elimination it was this
type of selfless dedication to the cause
of bolshevism which earned him the
nickname of iron Felix and iron Felix
expected a similar dedication from his
agents working them to the brink of
human capacity several checklists
collapsed from exhaustion and were
immediately dismissed from the force
only those who kept up with the boss's
stamina could aspire to rise through the
ranks and be hailed as model checklists
without a hint of irony josinski
described these as men with a warm heart
a cool head and clean
in late 1921 the Bolshevik government
was on its way to Victory against the
White Russian armies Lenin and his
people's commissars felt more secure in
their seats of power and decided to
scale back the state of emergency as a
result Checker the extraordinary
commission was closed down and replaced
by a new security organization still
under josinski as its chairman I had
Felix's new force was founded in
February 1922 with the name of State
political Administration known by its
Russian acronym GPU in November 1923 the
GPU became the O GPU or joint State
political Administration and in between
those dates in April 1923 josinski found
the time to create a sporting
Association dedicated to members of the
GPU and the Red Army the Dynamo Moscow
later spawned professional clubs across
17 different sports including football
basketball and ice hockey jersey and his
operatives were now placed under
stricter control having to report to the
ministry of the Interior this meant that
the ogpu was not free any longer to
execute that will their targets but they
continued to relentlessly hunt down
enemies of the state since Joseph
Stalin's appointment as General
Secretary of the Communist Party in 1922
the list of enemies included internal
political Rivals such as Leon Trotsky
and to sympathizers iron Felix was all
too happy to align himself with the man
of steel and he became his enforcer to
this end but the ogpu continued to crack
down on old classic adversaries namely
spies from Western Powers one of
josinski's Master Strokes was the
elimination of Georgie Rosenblum AKA
Sydney Riley aka the Ace of spies a
russian-born adventure in the employee
of British secret Services Riley had
been involved in previous plots to
assassinate Lenin and was believed to be
an act of danger to the Soviet
government under josinski's Direction no
GPU agent Alexander yakushev created a
fake underground group The monarchist
Association of central Russia ostensibly
aimed at murdering Bolshevik leaders
aakashev's bogus group invited Riley to
the Soviet Union and the Spy fell into
the Trap the aces fires was arrested by
the ogpu on September 26 1925 while he
was crossing the Finnish border Riley
was then take until Ivanka headquarters
for questioning while he initially
refused to cooperate eventually wrote a
letter to trezinski offering to betray
British and American secret agents
operating in Russia it was not clear
whether josinski accepted this offer but
what is certain is what happened next
Riley's execution on November the 5th
following direct orders from Stalin
clearly the all-powerful Soviet dictator
had no qualms and executing enemies but
he occasionally appeared to greatly care
about his most trusted collaborators and
josinski was one of them since February
1924 iron Felix the workaholic had added
several job titles to his resume he had
been elected member of the politic
Bureau the Soviet communist party's
policy-making body he had been appointed
chairman of the Supreme Council of the
national economy of the Soviet Union in
charge of coordinating economic
management bodies of local and National
levels and he still performed his duties
as chairman of the ogpu traveling across
the Soviet Union personally reviewing
the effectiveness of the forces law
branches such was his workload that
Stalin was concerned about his health
the leader ordered him to cut down his
to-do list and seek medical attention in
fact throughout 1924 and 1925 iron Felix
mostly focused his attention on economic
and social projects one of his most
successful projects was the creation of
a network of Institutions to look after
children orphaned during the Civil War
his orphanages and children's communes
provided free medical care food
education to children who otherwise
would have lived in the streets
despite Stalin's advice to take it easy
it appears that a hectic schedule
eventually took its toll on iron Felix
on July the 20th 1926 Felix dejanitsky
delivered a two-hour long speech to the
politic Bureau thundering against the
trotskis faction shortly after his talk
janitsky collapsed suddenly stricken by
a fatal heart attack I'm Felix have been
the head of the first incarnations of
the Soviet Secret Police and secret
service agencies for a little over eight
years and yet his legacy would be felt
for decades as successes of the Checker
and the ogpu continued to enact his
ruthless methods in 1934 the ogpu became
the nkvd which later became the MGB and
finally in 1954 the KGB the three-letter
acronym which plagued the nightmares of
Western intelligence agencies during the
Cold War four years after the Inception
of the KGB in 1958 the legacy of Felix
jazinski himself was honored by Soviet
Premier Nikita Khrushchev with the
unveiling of a colossal statue in
lebanca square in Moscow I'd Felix now
memorialized and granite could keep an
eternal watch over the headquarters of
the agency that he had founded and
directed Soviet propaganda had enshrined
his status as a hero of the Revolution
who had protected the young people's
government from its adversaries but
Russian citizens saw him in a different
light unsurprisingly as the Soviet Union
was crumbling in August 1991 his statue
was one of the first icons of the regime
to be taken down
foreign